قال مستشار الامن القومي العراقي قسم
الاعرجي ان القياده العراقيه لا تقبل باي
انتهاك لسياده البلاد من قبل ايران وتركيا
واضاف الاعرجي ان رئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شياع السوداني سيبحث في طهران
الثلاثاء القادم بشكل جندي خرق طهران
لسياده العراقيه وقل الاعرج انه ستكون
هناك لجنه عليا بين بغداد واقليم كردستان
لتفاهم مع ايران وتركيا لايجاد حلول
للامن الوطني العراقي كان قد اعلن
الاربعاء الماضي وضعها خطه على مراحل
اعادت نشرق قواتنا على طول الحدود مع
ايران وتركيا وجاء هذا الاعلان بعد ان شهد
شمال العراق على مدى الايام الماضيه قصا
نفذته كله من تركيا وايران
ومقاره لفصائل كرديه معارضه للبلدين تقول
انقره وطهران انها متمركزه في اقليم كرد
العراق
[موسيقى]
للمناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بغداد
وافق الجابريه الباحث السياسي ومن عمان
رعد هاشم المحلل السياسي العراقي اهلا
بكمين اسم حالي ان ابدا من بغداد معك سيد
واثق سيد واثق موضوع خطه على مراحل اعاده
نشر لقوات على طول الحدود مع ايران وتركيا
هذا ما تحدث عنه مجلس الوزار الامن الوطني
العراقي طيب عسكر الحدود الهدف منها اي
تحرك من ايران سياتيه تحرك في المقابل من
العراق او الاعلان عن هذه الخطه ورساله لا
اكثر
نعم شكرا جزيلا لكم تحيي لكم مشاهديكم
الكرام
طبعا طبيعه الحال هذه القضيه طبعا هي
المشكله مع ايران هي ذاتها مع تركيا يعني
موجود مجاميع وهذه المجامح هي مسلحه
وتنطلق من الاراضي العراقيه باتجاه
الدولتين يعني سواء اتجاه تركيا او ايران
وائل الدستور العراقي يمنع
سنتحدث عن القوانين ولكن اود ان يكون هذا
النقاش يسمح لي استاذ همم نحدد الجهه
العراقيه في علاقتها مع ايران ربما في
حلقه اخرى تتحدث على تركيا ولكن لعلاقه
كذلك ايران بالعراق مناقشه امكانيه تحرك
بشكل او باخر هذا ممكن
لا هو العراق لا يستطيع التحرك لا باتجاه
تركيا ولا باتجاه ايران ولا يريد ان يخذ
حربا او يرد بالمثل لكن هي المشكله في
الداخل العراقي يعني هي يعني هذه وجود هذه
المجامع في داخل العراق يعني تحتاج الى حل
عراقي مشكله العراقي يعني بدات في شمال
العراق في كردستان ان القوات العراقيه غير
منتشره على الحدود مع هذه الدول
عدم وجود قوات يعني سواء قوات التحاديه
سواء كان الشرطه اتحاديه او جيش او حتى
يعني من همم قوات يعني من القوات الاخرى
كجهاز مكافحه الارهاب لا يستطيع التحرك
داخل اقليم كردستان القوات الامنيه
العراقيه بينها وبين قوات كردستان بحدود
40 كيلو متر يسمى الخط الازرق دون تداخل
هذه القوات وايضا القوات الامنيه لا تمتلك
القدرات يعني من الدفاعات الجوي ولا من
الكاميرات ولا من الحركه سواء يعني تقريبا
هي ليس لديها اي صلاحيه
منع من سلطات الاقليم سلطات الاقليم ربما
هي متماهيه معه تواجد يعني سواء الاتراك
الكرد الاتراك او الكرد الايرانيين في
الشمال بعلى اساس قومي وهذه مشكله عراقيه
لحد الان التفاوضات بين حكومه الاقليم
ويعتقد الوفد الذي جاء من كردستان الى
بغداد هو بهذا الصدد من اجل حل هذه
الاشكاليات وامكانيات حراسه الحدود ومنع
انتقال هؤلاء سواء الى ايران او الى تركيا
هذه يمكن ان تحل من داخل العراق مع توصيات
هذه الدول بعدم اختراق سياده طبعا اكيد
خلق السياده من قبل ايران او تركيا طبعا
هو مرفوض بالنسبه للعراق مستعجل طبعا معظم
القوى السياسيه مجمع رغم علاقاتها مع
ايران لكن لا تستطيع ان تدافع عن همم خلق
الحدود او قتل المدنيين داخل العراق ما
رايك هل هي مشكله داخليه تخص العراق فقط
او ان هذه التحركات تضعنا في اطار اخر
نتحدث عن تهديد لسياده العراق
يعني بالتاكيد هذا الوضع شاذ وفي جنبه
اعتداء قانونيه واضحه
وتحتاج الى يعني جراحه اقليميه ليست فقط
بمعالجه داخليه
الوضع السياسي
والامني يختلط هنا في هذه القضيه في هذه
المساله تحتاج
الموضوع كان يحتاج الى معالجه منذ سنوات
لانه الان تذكرت ايران عنده لديها معارضين
من الكوملايه الايرانيه او الاكراد
الايرانيه الان تذكرت يعني مع تزامل
الاحتجاجات
واتذكره الان انها تهدد الامن القومي
الايراني وتذكرت الان بان على العراق ان
يملا هذه المنطقه او يشعرها امنيا هذه
حقيقه كلها التساؤلات تثير حفيظه
المتابع اللي همم
هاجي اول همم المهني لانه حقيقه هذه تبعث
على رسائل سريه همم رغم
ان كان هذا الموضوع وتشير الى
ان وهذا هو الواقع لماذا الان اتت هذه
التحركات ولماذا الان اتفتح هكذا مجال
محاوله ايجاد اليات لتسويه معينه
تصلها مخاطر من تلك المنطقه واحنا
بالمقابل ايضا نقول تصلنا مخاطر الى
الداخل العراقي على طول الحدود ليس فقط في
كردستان من جراء المخدرات الايرانيه ونحن
ايضا نقول انه ايران تهدد امن البلد بهذه
المنافذ الحدوديه المفتوحه معها
ومفتوحه مع سوريا من قبل ميليشياتها
بتهديد امن العراق وتهريب السلاح ان كانت
تدعي تهريب السلاح كما تقول اذا القضيه
مشتركه يجب ان تحل
باهتمام متبادل ليس فقط من جانب احادي ولا
العراق تعال الان ازرع هذه المناطق الوعره
الجبليه على
الثلج والشتاء
والمنطقه يعني حقيقه لا يقدر عليها الا
اهلها تستطيع ان تجلب ابن البصره لكي
يقاتل او يتواجد على الح هناك يمنع كومالا
ويمنع جيش ايراني من الصعب الان تدريب
وتهيئه القدرات الامنيه ما سيحصل انه
تعزيز قدرات الحدود بالتنسيق مع البيشمركه
ومع عملنا شيء ايضا هم البيشمركه موجودين
كخط ساند والحدود ايضا موجودين لكن ليست
بكثافه يجون ثلاثه الاف
يجون من 10 الى 30 خليه او او منفاد او
نقتح حدوديه يعززون هذا الشيء بين صعب
لانه خط طويل من الحدود ومن الوعوره ومن
الغامل القديمه السابقه من وقت الحرب
العراقي الايرانيه هذه
تجعل من العراق حقيقه في حرج من امريكا
لانه ترمي همم بهؤلاء المقاتلين الى حقول
الغام مثلا او الى مخاطر عدم امتلاكههم
سوى بندقيه يعني سلاح بسيط هذه تستصعب
المهمه وتصعب
همم عمليه تنفيذ هذه انسيابيه استاذ
واسع العراق
تمتلكان قوه حقيقيه لحراسه هذه الحدود
ولتحرك اذا
اي تحرك مقابل من جانب ايران كيف ستحافظ
الحكومه المركزيه على سيادتها التي لن
تتنازل عنها كما قلت منذ قليل قلت بانه
همم مرفوث اي تحرك همم قد يضر بسياده
العراق او قد يعتدي على سياده العراق من
جنب ايران همم حلول اذا
نعم يعني هو بالفعل يعني صعب على
البيشمركه يعني التعامل مع هكذا قضايا رغم
ادراكم تفاهمهم للطبيعه تلك المنطقه
وطبيعه جغرافيه ال ال الواعره صعبه
القاسيه ايضا في فصل الشتاء لكن الاشكاليه
طبعا البيشمركه ايضا بنفس الوقت لا يسمح
للقوات الحكوميه العراقيه يعني لتمتلك
التي هي اكثر تسلحا يعني مثل القوات حرس
الحدود وغير بالاضافه الى نقص التسلح لدى
القوات الامنيه همم العراق لا يملك منظومه
جويه متكامله ورصد ورادارات ومقاومه
الطائرات او حتى ممكن ان يحمل حدود يعني
عبر الوسائل المتاحه كالطائرات المسيره
والكاميرات الحراريه وغيره من الوسائل
طبعا هو ليس العراق فقط مسؤول عن حمايه
الحدود الدول ايضا ايران وتركيا ايضا هي
مسؤوله عن حمايه حدودها اذا كانت تدعي
هؤلاء يتسللون الى ايران فقط
توقف اا عند نقطه اثارت حضرتك لما تقول
بان القوات العراقيه لا يحق لها الدخول
الى اقليم كردستان العراق
وان البيشمركه هي التي ستتكفني وحدها
بتامين الحدود اذا في اي اطار اتت مساعي
الشياع همم محمشياع السوداني وفي ايطار
اتت كذلك تصريحات لمجلس الوزراء الامن
الوطني العراقي
يعني
قوات البيشمركه همم قوات جبليه هي متخصصه
في امن كردستان
الاقليم ولا يسمح للقوات الحكوميه الاخرى
التدخل والتجوال حتى اكبر المسؤول
العراقيين سواء كان وزير الداخليه هو وزير
الدفاع على لا يستطيع التجول دون اعلام
سلطه كردستان يعني او امن كردستان
وبالتالي يعني هذه القضايا المفروض هنالك
قضايا محليه ممكن ان تكون يعني للمحافظات
والاقليم هي يعني بحراسه داخل المدينه
اما بقيه القضايا فهي بالمفترض ان تكون
اتحاديه يعني حراسه الحدود
طبيعه مراقبه الطائرات والاختراقات التي
تحدث للدول وهذه غير متفقين نقط خلاف لذلك
السيد السوداني يعني عقده مع مجلس الامن
الوطني وعقد ايضا اليوم لديه تفاوضات مع
همم رئيس اقليم كردستان بارزاني قد نصل
الى تف هذه التفاهمات هي التي يمكن ان
تحمي الطرفين تحمي حكومه كردستان والاقليم
من هذه التهديدات او من النوم من الحكومه
او من الشعب العراقي وكذلك تخلى مسؤوليه
الحكومه او تحمل المسؤوليه براد المقابل
الرد ان اقول ليس الرد على هذه الدول فقط
بالسلاح وكذا هو انه ممكن استخدام ملفات
اخرى ممكن ملفات اقتصاديه دبلوماسيه
سياسيه غيرها من القضايا التي تربط مصالح
العراق مع هذه الدول يمكن الضغط على هذه
الدول ومنعها من اختراق سياده العراق وعدم
دخولها الحدود العراقيه دون اذن اذا اذا
كانوا يدعون يعني
الوقت يدركنا همم
هل ما يطرحه ضيفي يمكن ان يكون واقعيه
على الاقل بان تكون هناك ملفات تضغط بها
حكومه بغداد على هذه الدول مبينها ايران
حكومه بغداد قاد على ذلك وقادره بموازاه
ذلك ان همم تكون هناكاهمات بينها وبين
اقليم كردستان على امكانيه ايجاد حلول
العراقيه ليست لديها الرغبه او حتى
الاراده على الضغط على ايران باي ملف كان
رغم انه هناك فعلا ملفات كما قال الاخوه
همم قادر على ان يعني لو ارادت او لو توجد
لديها اراده سياسيه هي حتى
الاعتداء الايراني لم تدين القوه
الايطاليه الموجوده في البرلمان فكيف
تريدين ان تضغط على ايران في ملفات ماء
هناك حقيقه يبدو يعني حضور او تفاعل
امريكي يعني مجسد باعضاء الورد الكونغرس
الذي نزار والعراق ازارو ايضا كردستان همم
تفاهمات ممكن ان تحصل عبر واجهه امريكيه
في التفاعل المتبادل ما بين واحده طبعا
امر غريب يعني ان يحصل لكن هو الوضع
الحالي كما هو عليه همم صار الى تنسيق
متبادل كما في كردستان همم مع الدعم
الجانب اقليم كردستان في مقاتله داعش على
غرار هاتيه يتم انتشار وحدات ولكن ليست
عسكريه عراقيه اتحاديه انما همم حرس حدود
من قبيل البيشمركه وما يتطوع منها
الانتماء الى انه هذه الخطوه هي يعني
ستكون همم يعني همم ليست مؤقته بقدر ما هي
يعني تستغرق وقت طويلا اي بدايتها الان
كواجه يعني ارضائيه لايران همم تنفذ
بمراحلها الاولى ومراحل طبعا يعني متواضعه
وخجوله ربما تمهيدا لخطوات اخرى لاحقه
ربما تطول ثناء او سنتين وهنا همم
نتوقع سنتوقع ان همم تستغل ايران هذا
الوضع وتبدي همم باحراف او خالق مشاكل
اوسع على هذه الملف
كلنا طرح نقطه اخرى القدره مقابل الرغبه
ربما صنعوه لذلك في حلقاتنا القادمه اود
شكرا لكم جزيل الشكر من بغداد وثق
الجابريها الباحث السياسي هو من عمان رعد
هاشم المحلل السياسي العراقي شكرا لكم